hey guys Luke here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and my sister and her
kids are over at my house visiting and
they brought something called a feisty
pet see these cute little things yeah
you just like squeezing back here and
they they go from cute to evil evil any
rate we're going to go and show these to
my youngest Nathan see we can't scare
the crap out of him so it's not to be
pretty good
[Music]
I'm going to eat you do the Gary daddy
Kate thanks for watching
we hope you enjoyed this video if you'd
like to see more great videos from the
outdoor boys YouTube channel click
subscribe also I'll put a link in the
description to where you can learn more
about feisty pets thanks for watching we
hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you'd like to see more great videos from
the outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every week and don't forget to
hit that Bell button so you'll get
notified when we put out another great
video